Mr Speaker if he wants to talk about the
fact that Scotland is energy rich but
fuel poor on westminster's watch I am
more than happy to do so but for today
let's reflect upon numbers and in
particular those numbers that were shown
away on by Sam Coates of sky in
particular those in relation to the
prime minister's favorite potential
successor which showed over the course
of four months from four speeches he
raked in in excess of a million pounds
does a prime minister not find it
utterly perverse that senior members of
the conservative party are Feathering
their nest in this way whilst at the
same time seeking to deny working people
the opportunity to strike for fair pay
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I did I don't think we need
to talk about our predecessors but I
reckon I remember I remember
I think it was one of his predecessors
that did indeed work for Russia today if
I'm not mistaken
[Applause]
but today is
oh geez you
've been talking yet more about
independence at a time when we should be
talking about delivering for people
across the United Kingdom focusing on
their jobs improving the NHS across the
UK in Scotland as need as in everywhere
else that's the kind of thing I want to
talk to the Scottish government about
and I hope that he'll work with me to do
that
[Music]